memory mapping and streaming
in this video we'll take a look at two
core features of the datasets library
that allow you to load and process huge
datasets without blowing up your laptop
cpu
nowadays it's not uncommon to find
yourself working with
multi-gigabyte-sized data sets
especially if you're planning to
pre-train a transformer like bert or
gpt-2 from scratch
in these cases even loading the data can
be a challenge
for example the c4 corpus used
pre-trained t5 consists of over 2
terabytes of data
to handle these large datasets the
datasets library is built on two core
features the apache arrow format and a
streaming api
arrow is designed for high performance
data processing and represents each
table like data set with a column-based
format
as you can see in this example
column-based formats group the elements
of a table in consecutive blocks of ram
and this unlocks fast access and
processing
arrow is great at processing data at any
scale but some datasets are so large
that you can't even fit them on your
hard disk
so for these cases the datasets library
provides a streaming api
that allows you to progressively
download the raw data one element at a
time
the result is a special object called an
iterable data set that we'll see in more
detail soon
let's start by looking at why arrow is
so powerful
the first feature is that it treats
every data set as a memory map file
now memory mapping is a mechanism that
maps a portion of a file or an entire
file and disk to a chunk of virtual
memory
this allows applications to access
segments of an extremely large file
without having to read the whole file
into memory first
another cool feature of arrow's memory
mapping capabilities is that it allows
multiple processors to work with the
same large data set without moving it or
copying it in any way
this zero copy feature of arrow makes it
extremely fast for iterating over a data
set
in this example you can see that we
iterate over 15 million rows in about a
minute just using a standard laptop
that's not too bad at all
let's now take a look at how we can
stream a large data set the only change
you need to make is to set the streaming
equals true argument in the low dataset
function
this will return a special iterable
dataset object which is a bit different
to the dataset objects we've seen in
other videos
this object is an iterable which means
we can't index it to access elements but
instead we iterate on it using the ita
and next methods
this will download and access a single
example from the set which means you can
progressively iterate through a huge
data set without having to download it
first
tokenizing text with the map method also
works in a similar way
we first stream the data set and then
apply the map method with the tokenizer
to get the first tokenized example we
apply itter and next
the main difference with an iterable
data set is that instead of using a
select method to return examples we use
the take and skip methods because we
can't index into the data set the take
method returns the first n examples in
the data set while skip as you can
imagine skips the first n and returns
the rest
you can see examples of both of these
methods in action
where we create a validation set from
the first 1000 examples and then skip
those to create the training set